i've never asked you
how is it that you believe
from the moment you come into the world
you and your brothers know your purpose
but the rest of us have to seek these
things on our own hey guys pete here
this will be my breakdown for foundation
season one episode six if you were
missing the cleons death and the maiden
gave us a double dose we get two stories
focusing on brother day and brother dawn
who are both in different locations we
also get some movement on terminus and
some more hints about what harry selden
was up to and we will get into all of
that after a quick spoiler warning if
you haven't watched episode 6 yet then
this video won't be for you and with
that out of the way let's get into it
the sixth episode opens with another
narration from the future from gail
talking about trantor and the emperor
that would live forever the man who had
triumphed over death itself the leader
who never knew doubt in all his
lifetimes until he met harry selden on
his ship we see that the current brother
day cleon the 13th if you're keeping
track was a little messed up from the
hyperspatial travel of the jump
considering the active ruler has never
left the planet since the genetic
dynasty took over we could presume that
he probably hasn't experienced this
before unless it happened when he was
younger out of curiosity he asked
demarzel what it's like to be awake
during the trip he mentions that the
spacers who are there watching over
humans as they travel are engineered for
it but he barely considers them human
this may turn out to be important later
but what stands out about it now is that
these spacers are something different
than what we know about from asimov's
other work demarzel tells him that when
space folds the human mind can't
tolerate the discontinuity which makes
us wonder why gales could whenever she
woke up during her first trip on a jump
ship there's another question of what
demarzel was actually doing when he
walks in on her it looks like she's
repairing her face so does she have to
do routine maintenance when i first saw
it i thought maybe that's how she
prepares herself to go in front of
people but then later we find out that
she wasn't planning on leaving the ship
anyway in case you forgot she's a robot
as they approach their destination we
learn a lot about luminism as they talk
it's 15 000 years old it predates the
empire three trillion people believe in
this faith and they wear crystals made
of salt that come from the leviathan
mines and they pray by ritualistically
touching it which is something we've
seen demerizel do in previous episodes
because yeah she does actually believe
in this religion brother day doesn't
understand it he says that she has a
purpose to serve him and his brothers in
the empire it's actually built into her
code and she explains by saying that the
search for meaning is not always about
the answer it's also the process of
seeking that enlightens so the show is
building up its own lore here
zephyr halima is definitely a threat to
the emperor's power and we see that she
has some pull when she's the first
person to welcome him on his arrival the
fact that she's by herself that there's
no big welcome for the ruler of the
entire galaxy takes him out of his
element this all looks pretty great
especially the ship coming into the salt
palace and it's all in service to the
premise that there's going to be a new
proxima the previous one died brother
day meets with zephyr galat who is the
one that's on his side she's in the lead
to become the next proxima but the vote
could go towards halima he tries to tip
the scales by pledging to have the
empire build a moon-wide desalination
plant so that everyone there will have
fresh water which seems to solidify
things for galat until the rebirth
ceremony for the previous proxima is
interrupted by halima who just sort of
walks in and makes this crazy moving
speech for everyone there where she says
that the greatest crime against the
mother is stagnation which is basically
saying that the genetic dynasty goes
against their faith the crowd is moved
even demarzel bows with the others and
that leaves day as the odd man out it's
not as if they're in a frenzy against
the existence of the emperor but you can
see that she's opening the door and may
be charismatic enough to take them there
so while brother days in a struggle to
win the hearts and minds of the
followers of the luminous faith brother
dawn is struggling with how different he
is from those that came before him we
see this play out with the zora the
gardener who saw him jump from his
balcony and when brother dust takes him
hunting on his first time out he kills
twice as many as dusk's record which he
knows might be a problem so he takes
three of those and throws them in the
bushes and tries to make out like they
killed the exact same number brother
dusk tells him that only a man can
replace the man after their hunt and he
takes him to a brothel where we learn
that they sleep with women who have
their memories erased afterwards so they
don't have any recollection of what
happened he picks a woman that looks a
lot like a zora and then doesn't sleep
with her and we see that brother dusk
learns about this because he has her
brought to him before her memory is
wiped later we see dawn invite azor ah
into his room he wants to show her the
garden from the ledge outside his window
when she's reluctant to come out he
takes off his protective aura and offers
the letter put it on she declines and we
learn that he's colorblind and this is a
problem because he's different from all
the cleons that preceded him and maybe
this explains why he was so good at
hunting but it is one of his biggest
secrets and now she knows about it in a
gesture to earn his trust she steps
towards the edge and says if i were
trying to keep a secret i'd push me off
and instead of killing her on the spot
he decides to kiss her which is the last
that we see of these two then we see his
secret from the hunt get discovered by
the mysterious shadow master obrecht in
my episode 3 and 4 book to show video i
mentioned how this guy has shown up
twice 35 years apart and doesn't look
like he's aged at all and at the end of
his scene here he walks away and just
sort of disappears which i'm not sure
what they were actually going for there
it adds to his mystery and i hope we
find out more about what's going on with
this character in the next couple of
episodes on terminus the anacrion troops
are at the crash site for the jump ship
and we find out that they're looking for
dorwin who there sure survived because
the empire is as good at preserving
their people's lives as they are at
taking the lives of others back at
terminus city we see the aftermath of
the battle and we see two of the kids
from the first episode who survived it
does look like a lot of people died in
the attack salvor is still out cold
farrah decides to keep her alive because
she thinks she's the key to the vault
which is a big unknown at this point
doran is more important to their plan
and they need some encyclopedists and
she mentions that they need to get going
because the invictus won't wait forever
the kids were hiding they're eventually
able to rescue salvor who explains that
the invictus was a ghost ship it was
this legendary imperial destroyer that
disappeared so this is the big plan the
anacrion thinks that if they can get a
hold of this invictus it'll be their
redemption and they need some of those
encyclopedists who have special skills
that can help them take it over as far
as we can guess they tell them they just
need their help and that they'll leave
terminus after they get what they're
after at first the foundationers don't
want to help but a shot in the leg to
one of their loved ones gets the
cooperation that the anacrions need
salvo and the kids make it outside they
run into her dad and hugo she wants to
go after the corvettes and she believes
that it's possible that harry put her
there to stop the first crisis based on
this intuition she's been having how
she's feeling drawn to do certain things
and the vault waking up on their way
there her dad tells her about trantor
how things were actually pretty good at
least for his family but he says they
knew it was all built on lies and even
though he didn't really understand
harry's predictions he did want to get
with her mother and she actually did
believe in the plan so it's the father
and daughter moment which does feel a
little ominous as they approach the
ships
we see salvor take the lead even though
her dad wanted to go at first and as she
starts to put her plan in action she's
hit with a vision and is disabled right
there in the open on the ground and this
vision's even more vivid than the
previous ones where she's in gail's
clothes and we see that she's on the
slow ship we hear the conversation harry
and rach had before the murder harry
explains that there's only one scenario
where you leave the ship and that's the
one that makes it impossible for you to
remain on board i don't take my life you
do rach is not into this at all he tries
to say that you can fix this and harry's
pretty adamant he says everything
collapses because you stay here with her
referring to gail and that everything
would be wasted he says that the entire
galaxy is pivoting on the actions of an
individual you they go back and forth he
asks him if he trusts the math he says
he hates the math he asks him if he
trusts him and he said he wishes he
never met him and he says that the
cryopod is programmed for you don't stop
to say goodbye to her and he does go
ahead and stab him like we saw and at
that moment salvor walks in as gail did
and then in the present time hugo wakes
her up and it ends there they are seen
and a shootout breaks out where they
have the high ground in cover but her
father's out there on his own he's
trying to get to the ships with
explosives and he almost makes it as
salvor's picking off the soldiers but he
does get shot and then he ends up
sacrificing himself detonating the
explosive which takes out the corvettes
but kills him in the process
later after they get away salvor has
another crisis of faith she thinks that
everything that's going wrong is her
fault she tells hugo what she heard
harry say and again he thinks she's
special and she's resistant to the idea
but now that her father's dead she's
really motivated to get revenge against
farrah the episode comes to an end when
they try to sneak back to his ship
they're caught right away because what
else is pharah actually doing but
waiting after they destroyed the
corvettes she orders her men to kill
salvor and hugo transfers control of his
ship he slaves it to her so that they'll
need her alive and they need him also
because she doesn't know anything about
piloting a ship so farah has everything
she needs and they load up and the
episode ends with them leaving the
planet it feels like things are closing
in on brother dawn i can't imagine he
has much actual freedom considering his
status which means his meeting with azor
ah is probably known and when you add
that to shadowmaster obrecht finding the
extra kills and the sex worker reporting
back to dusk suspicion has to be
mounting brother day's predicament is
serious and i guess it complicates
things having demersel torn between the
empire and the faith i'm not sure what
else to say about this because it's all
been set up so far he's gonna have to
find a way to bring halima down and she
does seem like a worthy adversary oh
terminus well we do know why pharah and
her people showed up now they needed a
member of the imperial military and some
scientists to get themselves a legendary
jump ship that disappeared sometime in
the past i suppose this is what we saw
happening in the trailer where salvor
was out in the vacuum in a suit and she
lost her father here which could be a
turning point for the character but the
visions of harry selden and rach were
kind of a bigger deal now we know for
sure why harry had rage take his life he
wanted to ensure that after it was done
rach would be forced to leave in the pod
and to get away from gail where it gets
muddy is this whole thing of salvor as
gail being there seeing it are these
visions connected with the feeling that
gail had that caused her to run in and
see this murder in the first place since
we don't know any more about gail's
mysterious feelings they don't really
explain salvor's visions something is
going on in relation to these two
characters but other than picking things
that happened out of the books and
trying to apply them i don't think the
show's given us enough to make sense of
it and the same goes for demersal we
can't really say why the only robot in
the show the last of her kind as it were
would be religious other than what she
told brother day in the episode we don't
know how her kind was taken out how she
came into service of cleon the first or
if regular people in the story know
she's a robot outside of the emperor's
the fact that harry said the entire
galaxy is pivoting on the actions of an
individual and there's this idea that
everything would collapse if rach stayed
with gail makes me really hope that we
see him again in the next episode i'd
like a further explanation of what's
going on there and i suppose we're
getting to the point in the season where
we should start to get a better
understanding of all these things and i
think that's a good place to leave it
let me know your theories in the
comments and what you think about this
episode please mark any book spoilers if
you want to discuss them please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon